i think it would probably be better if
we in the political community if we
conservatives could get together
and go in and say no we're going to
assert our rights as americans and take
this power back from left-wing silicon
valley oligarchs
but we can take what we can get all
right if elon musk is the best way for
us to go in
and retake some of this political
control then that's the thing that we're
going to do
and maybe that means musk buys twitter
maybe that means musk just destroys
twitter maybe that means musk never
wanted to buy twitter in the first place
and this was all a long troll to destroy
the company which increasingly it seems
like it was elon musk tweeted out the
other day
quote 20
fake spam accounts
while four times what twitter claims
could be much higher
my offer was based on twitter's sec
filings being accurate
yesterday twitter's ceo publicly refused
to show proof of less than five percent
bot accounts
this deal cannot move forward until he
does
so do you see what's happened here
all the while we've been waiting all of
elon's cryptic messages he's quoting
poetry he is he's suggesting he'll maybe
join the board he won't join the board
he'll make a tender offer he doesn't
need to make the tinder of he's going to
go he and what is he doing
they said if the if the board rejects
your your bid
elon what are you going to do he says
i've got a plan b i'm not going to tell
you what that is now
well plan b or c or d might not even be
buying twitter it might just be
destroying twitter
because he's saying look i made my offer
of whatever it was 44 billion dollars or
something
based on the idea that twitter has less
than five percent bot accounts
now does anyone believe that fewer than
five percent of the accounts on twitter
are bots and spam
i don't i'm just a regular twitter user
i think it's that number is way higher
if you use twitter surely you're going
to think that number's way higher elon
musk uses twitter a lot and he looked
into it enough to potentially buy
twitter you don't think
that elon musk maybe thought huh i think
i think twitter's official filings on
the spam body counts they're probably a
little low no i think he probably
suspected they were
a little low
and so he goes in and he makes the offer
and then it goes all the way along here
and then he says wait a second
i'm looking over your
securities and exchange commission
filings here and
you know it's looking to me like you
might have been dishonest on some of
your filings with the government it's
looking to me like you might be
committing some fraud against your
investors here
sho proves to me that fewer than five
percent of your accounts are bots and
spam and the ceo of twitter the
for now the ceo of twitter prague
agrawal
said no we can't do that i wish we could
but there's no way we don't have any
access to show and elon just responded
with the little feces emoji
right underneath he said ah i'm pretty
sure you can but you don't want to
because what it's going to show is that
you guys are perpetrating a fraud
whatever elon does here whether he buys
it and opens up speech for conservatives
a little bit at least to some degree or
if he just destroys twitter either way
that will be a positive development
either way i cheer him on i don't know
which is funnier i actually can't decide
which is fine it's it's a longer term
joke if elon runs twitter and gets to
troll from twitter
but
it is a spectacular magnificent joke if
he just does all of this
to destroy twitter for perpetrating a
fraud he would be destroying it not just
to
troll them and get get his kicks he
would be doing it with a purpose he'd be
he actually would be exposing a fraud he
actually would be improving speech in
the public square
that would it's it's as i frequently say
it is not enough to own the lips it's
good to own the lips i'm pro owning the
lips but you one needs to own the lips
with purpose
you don't want to be frivolously owning
the lips
why is elon doing all of this is he
sincere what's his endgame
a lot of people have pointed out that
elon musk is a lib
he's a democrat he's an obama democrat
he voted for obama twice i believe
well now elon says
he's officially a republican he tweeted
out
or i don't know if he tweeted this i
don't know how much he's using twitter
these days but he at least stated i have
voted overwhelmingly for democrats
historically
like i'm not sure i might never have
voted for a republican just to be clear
now this election i will
he posted a meme the other day of him
standing still
to the left of center you had the you
had the left of the political island the
right of the political aisle he was left
of center
and then
the leftists ran so far left and the
right
didn't really move the right actually
moved a little bit to the left and so
now all of a sudden elon having not
moved at all is center right
that's what happened and so is ilan a
republican is he being sincere i suspect
he probably is i think there are a lot
of people
who would have called themselves
liberals or leftists even or center-left
who now are firmly on the right because
they hold such radical positions as
don't chop off little kids genitals such
radical positions as don't kill little
babies one minute before they're born
such radical positions as hey maybe a
handful of woke bazillionaires shouldn't
completely dominate our political
discourse
and the establishment is trying
desperately to counter that narrative so
sunny hostin on the view insists no no
elon you're wrong no no most americans
you're wrong actually it's the
republicans who have moved much further
to the right
they are playing to the base i mean if
you look at all the studies the
republican party has moved further to
the right than democrats have to the
left there's a pew research center
analysis that finds that on average
democrats and republicans are farther
apart ideologically today than at any
time in the past 50 years and that
ideological divide breaks down to the
republican party being an extremist
party and the democratic party actually
as you just mentioned sarah moving more
to the center but isn't the problem that
is the primaries because you can't get
through these primaries unless you are
extreme especially right now in the
republican party
that claim that sonny hosting just made
is so ridiculous it almost isn't worth
responding to i will respond to it
because it's going to be a common
refrain in this election
on what issue have the democrats move to
the center
on what issue on abortion no they went
from safe legal and rare to abortion on
demand without apology up to the moment
of birth and maybe afterward on
immigration no they went from we've got
to keep illegal aliens out of our
country too we need completely open
borders and three million migrants
coming in per year two million of whom
are illegal on what on sexual issues no
we went from maybe teach sex ed in high
schools to we need to trans the
kindergartners i don't think so on on
what issue on what issue have they
become
on free speech no they went from let's
tolerate free speech too let's censor
all the conservatives and what they've
moved radically left on all of the
issues what about the republicans where
have they moved right on abortion
they're basically the same maybe they've
moved a little bit more pro-life on
abortion but basically they're the same
on guns no they're pretty much the same
on guns on
taxes if anything they've moved to the
center on on taxes and economic issues
on
the social issues on marriage oh my gosh
they
many republicans have just bought a
complete radical redefinition of
marriage given to them by the radical
left i don't think there on on what
issue on
if the republicans have moved at all and
i suppose they have they've moved
to the center
and i'm this is not just well the
leftists say that it's the other guys
who moved and it's the conservatives say
it's the other guy no you just look at
the issue by issue tell me where i went
wrong
i don't think i've said anything wrong
i'm giving specific examples i i can
prove my argument sonny hostin is just
spouting platitudes because her party
has moved radically to the left i am so
glad that you liked that clip now
you got to smash that button and ring
that like and jiggle that doodad and
make sure that you get the notifications
for the michael knowles show then you
can head on over to wherever you get
your audio podcasts for free not gonna
cost you a penny
spotify stitcher google play apple
podcast wherever type in the michael
knowles show you scroll you find you see
my swarthy sultry face you click on it
you subscribe you leave a five star
review at least i hope
and then we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]